A very common problem is to find the largest element in a sequence of inputs.
Now you might think, how hard can this be? In this sequence, clearly this one
is the largest. But a computer program can't scan all of the inputs at once
like we can. The computer sees items one at a time. So, let's look at this
problem a little differently. So here I have these playing cards. I get to see
one at a time. And I need to find out which one has the highest value. Let's
look at the first one. That clearly is the largest one I've seen so far. The
next one, well, that one is larger. The next one is even larger. This one here,
not so much, so I won't change my mind about which one is the largest. That one
is larger yet. This one isn't as large as the one over here,so we will ignore
it and my last one here is also smaller, so my answer is that 8 was the largest
input. In pseudocode the algorithm would look like this, I start at letting the
largest be the first value while there are more values I read the next value.
And if that value is larger than what I thought the largest was, I changed my
mind. When I'm done with this loop, largest would have been set to the very
largest of all the inputs. Now you get to try this out with Java code, go ahead
and complete the next project.